- Hey, you guys must be in a band, huh?
- [Both] Yeah.
- I know a bunch of managers.
I could actually reach out.
- Are you sure you want to
text while you're driving?
- Come on man, I'm an Uber driver in L.A.
- Yeah, but it's like, super dangerous.
- So is kicking a cop.
Oh no, my bank account's been frozen.
♫ Over 1.6 million car crashes occur
♫ Because of texting and driving each year
♫ Or using your Facebook or
checking your email or Twitter
♫ Each time a new update appears
♫ It's sad to think that nobody stops
♫ After all of the damage
it's done to mankind
♫ And when I think of the
articles and studies I've read
♫ There's only one thought
that goes through my mind
♫ That won't happen to me
♫ Oh no, sir, not I
♫ I yell at my buddies 'cause
I've seen all the studies
♫ And sometimes, people die
♫ That won't happen to me
♫ No, not to this guy
♫ I hate it, although I've
got to keep in the know
♫ So, I'm probably gonna reply
♫ I drive really carefully
♫ I always look out for other cars
♫ In my blind spots and mirrors
♫ I make sure all pedestrians
have plenty of room
♫ Plus I've been driving for years
♫ But when I hear a vibration
♫ It's a real struggle
♫ Not to check my phone every five
♫ Is it wrong when my friend
lost her cell phone last week
♫ I asked her what she'd do on her drives
♫ That won't happen to me
♫ No, it sounds like a flaw
♫ I try to act like I'm
better, a real trend setter
♫ But I'm totally breaking the law
♫ That won't happen to me
♫ The conclusion's been drawn
♫ No, it might drive you ballistic
♫When I hear the statistics
♫ I say la la la la la la la la la la
♫ It's so boring to be in a fast metal box
♫ In between other fast metal boxes
♫ I need something exciting
♫ And my phone's so inviting
♫ It will help me from getting exhausted ♫
(car crash)
- See that? That could've been you.
- It's super dangerous.
- Whatever. That won't happen to me.
♫ That won't happen to me
♫ That only happens to others
♫ Their sisters and brothers
♫ Although, you might disagree
♫ That won't happen to me ♫